it's it's we work on it like it's
against Parma this was against Parma
yeah
where football is a religion brexit was
something of a miracle for AC Milan
footballer Carl Heffernan basically
brexit changed her life in a way yeah it
did it did like um
because
if breaks it hadn't happened I probably
could be in England though I'm not
saying for sure I'd be in England but it
probably it would be a good bit of the
way there you know the 17 year old from
Cork was the subject of intense interest
from English clubs which ended abruptly
as post-brexit rules on underage players
kicked in I've been on a couple of
trails in Italy as well here
and then thankfully I landed this one in
Milan so it just changed my life
completely so I'm kind of happy it
happened in a way but you know obviously
it would have been nice to go to England
as well he's not alone with fellow Irish
youngsters heading off to Italian and
French clubs an increasing number of
Irish players are now ending up here in
Italy and other European countries
instead of heading to British clubs
which since brexit now have to wait
until players from the EU are aged 18 or
over and that puts those clubs at a
distinct disadvantage I think it is it's
a massive disadvantage for England and I
don't like they're gonna have to figure
out a way in the future to try
counteractive because if they don't
they're going to end up paying the price
because as the European clubs are just
going to start taking over and they're
going to get the best players from all
around the Europe you know back in
Dublin the new rules put pay to 17 year
old Adam Murphy's prospects of an
English move but he's relishing the
alternative opportunities it's a new
window that's kind of a chord since
um brexit has come into place as a young
lad
the dream is to make it across the water
and play in the UK but now it's shown
you that that European option is there
whereas a few years ago it would have
been really unusual a leading Academy
director here says brexit has been a
game changer the clubs in Europe are
actually realizing that as America in
Ireland
those those clubs that would have
accepted that it would have been normal
for Irish boys just to go over to the UK
same language same culture same field
and they'll see in a massive Gap in the
market because we're still producing
excellent players in this country and if
they feel they can get them a little bit
quicker at 16 and they have one up on
the clubs in the UK who have to wait
till they're 18. and that's because of
brexit that's because of brexit now
Irish clubs are retaining their best
young players for a season or two longer
but that brings its own education and
Welfare challenges or like kahul their
part in the shop window for a dream move
to a football Giant on the continent
another unintended consequence of brexit
Stephen Murphy's Sky News in Milan